mother of Mary by the way we have a
chapter about her really yeah yeah look
this is your interest bro can I have a
what's the message saying this app has
been such a game changer to me I've
never been so consistent with my Quran
reading before I knew about Quran this
is how people's lives are changing and
you can get quranly absolutely free no
credit cards for seven day free trial
what are you waiting for download it now
belong sisters and build a habit with
the qurani app right now link for IOS
and Android in the link description
below alright so guys hope you guys are
well inshallah so we've got the dollar
table uh we're just speaking to a
brother please forgive me for ending the
conversation but yeah I saw uh sister
Madeline how you doing I'm fine thanks
that's good you had a question you said
that your friend had a question
um about about Islam and you haven't
read the Quran before right no I don't
okay sure so what's the question
um I'm asking what do you do what do you
do to people that don't believe in your
God okay are you ready to hear this yeah
it's gonna be very brutal I'm fine we
give them dawa we invite them to Islam
okay so I don't know what your friend
told you but people that don't believe
for example in Islam they're in
categories so there's the people of the
book so there's we as Muslims we believe
the Jews and the Christians are people
of the book are you a Christian yeah
okay good so you we will cross you as
the people of the book so you are closer
to us than the polytheists so the
polytheists go down the categories of
idol worshipers so these are people who
worship statues you don't agree with
that I don't agree with that right
okay good so as Christians that's the
reason why Allah says in the Quran tell
the people of the book which is you we
come together and we worship God Alone
which you say the father yeah yes so in
another show we are commanded in Islam
that we can we live in harmony and peace
to give up with the Christians and the
Jews so when Islam was ruling the world
the vast majority of the world and lots
of Christians lived under the rule of
Islam in peace they had their own
Cathedrals their own churches their own
laws they could drink alcohol eat pork
in their vicinity so and they were a
protected group meaning for example the
prophetamination
he was one of the second Khalif of Islam
when he took over Jerusalem
he had a covenant a treaty with the
Christians and the Jews that they will
live side by side in peace and they have
rights if an external enemy was to come
and attack the Christians the Muslims
will be there to defend them
if an external enemy came to attack the
Jews the Muslims would be there to
defend them and the same goes if an
external enemy came to attack the
Muslims the Jews and the Christians will
help the Muslims to fight them so there
is a perception that in Islam it says
you know the disbeliever you kill them
nonsense this is only talking about
specific individuals who are hostile so
in the Quran in chapter 60 verse 8 Allah
says in the Quran we do not forbid you
from being just and kind to those who do
not fight you and kick you out from your
houses so in the notion to answer your
question sister Madeline we are told
that a principle is number one we share
Islam with everybody Christian Jew Hindu
whoever you are that's the number one
thing that we believe that the
disbelievers have a right because they
want to hear the message of Islam
that's number one number two if they
choose to reject it then thus upon them
because
it's the second chapter of the Quran
there is no compulsion in religion I
can't force you to accept Islam it
defeats the purpose if you unforced you
then you didn't really embrace it so in
Islam strictly nobody no muslim is
allowed to force a non-muslim to accept
Islam
okay if that makes sense yeah yeah sure
thank you any other questions no that's
it so let me talk just quickly I know
you need to go about what our belief is
in pertaining to our adoption we believe
there is one God we believe he's not a
man he's not a statue he's not an idol
there is nothing like him so are you a
Christian that believes Jesus to be God
do you believe Jesus to be God no I
think he's just he's he's just the
creature of him he's his son or he is
not God but are you Jehovah's Witness
denomination
um just a Catholic no Catholic okay so
good so you believe that for example the
mother of Mary by the way we have a
chapter about her really yeah yeah look
this is her interest bro can I have a
one second you know what a lot of
Christians don't know this yeah
but basically we have a chapter actually
not it's in my
life I'll show you
so look check this out sister yeah so
I'll open the Quran on my app oh yeah
look I'm gonna write there Mariam
chapter Mary
we've got a whole chapter on the the
name of the the mother of Jesus my name
is Merlin Marie
yeah so and Jesus is talked about in the
Quran as well we as Muslims I have to
believe in Jesus any Muslim that says he
doesn't believe in Jesus he can't be a
Muslim so we believe and also the Quran
came also to defend her honor because
the dreams said about her the Jews used
to say not all obviously the Jews back
in those times when Jesus came and we
believe in his miraculous birth we
believe in his miracles that he done we
believe he spoke in the crowd when he
was a baby he spoke to defend his mother
because the Jews used to say that they
used to claim married to be an adulterer
and the Quran comes to defend that that
this is not true we believe she was one
of the most amazing woman to walk this
Earth there are four that the prophet
Muhammad mentioned she's one of them she
was an amazing woman so we have utmost
respect for the mother of Jesus we have
utmost respect for Jesus and all we say
is the following
we should not worship anybody except God
this is the main Message of Islam all
the Muslims here we worship God Alone we
do not worship any idols and that's why
we tell the Christians that Jesus
because some believe Jesus is good we
say no how could a man be God would you
agree to yeah we call this the federal
you know what he said when I said it to
you we say you are programmed to know
this even if I didn't tell you about
Islam if I said to you do you believe
Jesus Is God you say no right yeah so
the main message Islam is what let's
worship the one true God and Jesus is
his Prophet yes like in the Bible it
says in Acts 2 2 verse 22 Jesus of
Nazareth a man chosen by God with
wonders Miracles and signs which God did
by him and you are a witness to him so
Islam in a nutshell States worship us
alone except you have the Old Testament
you have the New Testament this is the
final Testament this approves and talks
about the other Scriptures it affirms
Moses it affirms Jesus affirms Abraham
all it says is this is the final
Testament except this and believe in it
okay that's it if you have any other
questions
um yeah just wonderful we said God is
three types like holy ghost and holy
spirit his son and God himself what do
you think about that okay so Allah says
in the Quran do not say free meaning the
following
do you accept that God is the
all-knowing do you accept is all
powerful
yeah okay now Jesus in the Bible he
talks about him going to the fig tree
and he did not know the season for the
fix they asked Jesus when is the hour he
said I do not know no the angels in
heaven except the father so what Jesus
is saying if Jesus was God he would say
I am God and I'm going to tell you when
the hours yeah but he doesn't he says I
don't know not the angels in heaven
nobody except the father he always gives
credit to the father so we say the holy
spirit is Angel Gabriel the angel
Gabriel that came to Abraham Abraham
came to Moses came to Jesus and came to
Prophet Muhammad all with the one
message worship God alone so that's why
the Ten Commandments the first
commandment is what do not worship idols
yeah why because I God I'm a jealous God
if I go to jealous God yeah so what we
see is sister is that
do you believe that God should be one
and unique I think so yeah good so do
you believe that God could be a man no
thank you Islam in a nutshell is this so
I would say personally your Coast Islam
yeah
so I would say in a nutshell sister look
into Islam have you do anything about
the Prophet Muhammad
no not yet okay let me give you some
material can we give the scissor some
material okay I'll give you some
material about the problem so I'm going
to give you some material okay read it
in your own time but in a nutshell the
main fundamental Message of Islam is
worship God Alone he is the one who
created you and imagine I'll give you a
simple scenario you have a mother and
father yeah yeah okay they brought you
up they look after you they fed you to
this age Imagine you turn to your mom
and dad say you've done nothing for me
I'm gonna thank Ali My Name's Ali and
then I say I'm gonna say thank you to
Ali how would they feel
yeah so they will feel betrayed they
will feel like you're being ungrateful
to them now what we say is we don't say
God has feelings and gets hurt but we
say God is the one do you tell your
heart to beat
no do you tell your Langster brief more
or less but
they breathe the heart yeah the food
that we eat to the health that we have
to the family that we have the fact that
we can walk all of these are the
blessings of God now imagine I go and
say I'm gonna find this tree
this is one thing in Islam that God
doesn't forgive and what's different
with Christianity and Islam is the
following in Christianity God requires
blood sacrifice
Islam says no nobody needs to die no
blood sacrifice if you sinned you don't
need to I think it's Catholic you go to
the priest and confess
in Islam you don't go to any man you go
to God how
if you sins you say God forgive me the
Christians believe in if you pray enough
it's not enough but my my priest told me
I don't have to go to him or anyone else
I just have to pray and tell God about
it what bothers me and that's enough
good but when it comes to sins
confessing you need to go to the place
or can you repent to where you are I can
defense where we are good so in Islam
what we say is the same that we do not
go to any man if we sin we repent and
and there's a Hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad which means what he said he
said it's the sins of Adam we're the
sons of children of Adam if his sins
were to reach the mountains in the skies
God will forgive every single one of
them except shirk you know what shirk is
no okay ship is associating Partners so
if somebody comes and says I Think Jesus
is good or I think this tree is good or
I worship this or I worship that that is
the only thing God doesn't forgive
anything other than that God will
forgive so the main Message of Islam is
what worship
believe in something every person every
single person has to believe in
something and if it's not God it's
something else but you have to believe
in anything you see what he said there
it's very powerful because Allah says in
the Quran have you seen the one who
takes his desires as his own God so what
you said is correct every single one of
us believe in some kind of a good for
some people they've got this money for
some people they've got this opposite
gender for some people their God is
painting for some people they're golden
statues but we say worship the one true
God that is where you'll find your true
freedom because all these other things
are man-made everything in this universe
say worship the one that could be it a
creation